I gotta watch the Twitter feed I gotta
watch the Twitter feed people watching
online it's all these crazy got a weed
through that gun okay this is a joke oh
this is a real question
you know Tony Tyson and refers to LSST
like that yes
speaking of picky treats there is a
reception after the next talk just
outside and then why don't I introduce
Muncie now so motsi is the final talk of
the afternoon sort of winding into what
will be a real survey in two weeks not
even yeah not even two weeks a few days
with this wiki transient facility so her
talk is on real-time response to
understanding our dynamic Scott please
take it amongst all right so let's get
started good afternoon everyone
so we've as we've heard all day today
there's this is a really fun time to be
doing time domain astronomy there's a
whole set of discovery engines that are
coming online thanks to technological
advances in the optical the infrared the
high energy the radio just about every
wavelength you can think of there seems
to be a speed-up in the rate at which we
can make movies of the sky and image the
sky over and over again to look for time
variable phenomena so this this
explosion and discovery engines is
what's driving a lot of the energy and
excitement and science in this talk so I
just wanted to set that as the backdrop
but one if there's one point that I want
you to take away is that time domain
science now is is that a place where
rapid response follow-up is
so we can't wait for yours and go back
and look in archives and and do archival
science we really are trying to do
science in real time response has to be
super rapid so for example here you see
a northern projection of the of the
globe and this is just an example the
idea is that if say you discover an
event on beautiful Palomar Observatory
in Southern California just just a few
hundred miles south of here and I'll
tell you why this is my favorite
mountaintop but but I'm just a little
bit biased there okay but Palomar
Observatory say we discover something
now if you're discovering something
that's very young or very fast fading or
anything that's fading away disappearing
on our timescales then the biggest thing
have to contend with in this game is
sunrise so the Sun rises in a few hours
and you have to stop collecting data
from that mountaintop
so in that situation you have no choice
but to make friends with people around
the world and go west so west of
California is the Pacific Ocean but
thankfully there is the Island of Hawaii
with beautiful set of telescopes there
in amongst the biggest in the in the
world and then you can keep going to
Japan Taiwan India Israel Sweden in this
particular example to continue to
collect data and beat sunrise as you go
around the globe so this is what gives
you very rapid response and I'll give
you several examples of the kind of
science that something like this a
network like this enables and this
particular project here called growth is
is a National Science Foundation
partnership and international research
and education program so let's start
from the beginning this is the venerable
Palomar 48-inch telescope I think Josh
showed a picture of this as well this
has been around for decades this is and
this is in the let me just focus on the
last decade of what this fine telescope
has done it has a rich history than the
Palomar Observatory sky surveys and
several survey's even before then but I
just want to focus on the last decade
and the
so these that have happened from but
primarily the same team at the Panama
transient Factory survey that began in
2009 and then the in Tunisia palma trans
in factory survey and this brand new
camera that we are all very excited
about which is this vicky transient
facility which is a whopping forty seven
square degree camera this is a camera
the size of photographic plates so it's
literally silicon that's this much in in
size that's now been that fills up the
focal plane of this telescope and can
survey the sky at an unprecedented rate
but let's start right here from the
beginning the palma transient factory
was began on an old telescope with an
old camera it was a recycled camera from
another telescope they didn't really
care about that camera anymore but the
power of it was the software and the
follow-up the intermediate palma trance
in factory something we call an entirely
new project we got new partners new
funding was exactly the same hard way
but completely new software just
rewriting the software so and it's not
until this vicky transient facility that
we're really getting into shiny new
hardware here but software is is key and
integral to any of the science that is
being done and enabled by by these
survey's so so let me tell you what the
intermediate palma transient factory
software pipeline was about so this is a
the the real-time software pipe
detection pipeline of the intermediate
palma transient factory which was just a
rewrite of peters palma transient
factory pipeline and rewritten by a
graduate student so i mean nothing
dramatic here but extremely powerful
enough to define an entirely new project
that that does science that was just not
possible in the years before this here
is a flowchart of the different
components of the pipeline there's a lot
of information here in the morning
you heard josh describe the machine
learning box this box didn't even exist
a decade ago
and when Josh came up with this idea of
employing machine learning to
distinguish real sources from bogus
sources he really that I think started a
cottage industry we are now at the 5th
version of the V of the machine learning
algorithms that and training sets have
been proved and performance is improved
josh inspired a group at JPL and then at
Los Alamos National Lab to again
contribute new algorithms new ways of
approaching this problem and improving
the real bogus classification and as I
said we are already in the matter of a
few years as in the fifth generation of
this particular box which didn't even
exist when we when we started but all of
this rewriting of software that a
graduate student working with Peter each
how did was to improve the speed so this
is here a comparison of speed
performance from each other's papers
here and you can leave it exactly the
same hardware but rewriting the software
the the pipeline turnaround time which
had a median of something like thirty to
forty minutes came down to less than ten
minutes
and this factor of three to four
improvement made a huge difference to
the science and and I'll tell you again
in a few minutes on what impact this had
on the science with ztf now we have data
volume that's now an order of magnitude
larger because we have not only do we
have a camera with a much larger field
of view we also have electronics that
can read out the data and this camera
much much faster so instead of taking 40
seconds to read out this tiny little set
of chips here we now only take eight
seconds to read out this giant mosaic so
it's both improvements in camera
electronics as well as in in CCD
technology here that are making ztf and
a factor of 12 faster and volumetric
survey speed and a factor of 15 faster
in any real service speed than its
predecessor the Parliament
in factory and I'm happy to report this
Vicki transit facility camera has had
first light actually a couple of months
ago now this is our first light image
all of you I hope recognize the Orion
constellation this here is the field of
view of the cameras a single snapshot in
30 seconds we image this entire region
here of the Orion constellation and
since there is a pretty zoomin of the
Horsehead and the CTF which is what I'd
refer to this Vickie transient facility
as can now survey the sky at a rate of
three thousand seven hundred and fifty
square degrees an hour which means we
run out of sky to observe in a few hours
so no matter what we do we are as uber
fast heathens survey where we can repeat
large swaths of sky at a very rapid rate
and this is also important for the speed
theme and and the rare theme of
transients that I'll talk about I also
want to emphasize that ztf is a
public-private partnership it's funded
by the National Science Foundation with
skeeve Innovation Program and starting
the summer there will be a completely I
mean half the survey is public and half
the survey is private and the public
part of the survey which was an all-sky
survey at the three-day cadence in a
galactic plane survey at one decadence
will be streamed out for the entire
world to use starting the salmon it's an
exactly the same format as Eric Dunn
mentioned that LSST alerts would be so
those of you interested in in preparing
for LSST you have some real data and
real discoveries to work with so in
terms of software one of the major
improvements in ztf is that we've
changed the image subtraction algorithm
that we use so iran avec and as graduate
student Barack sake at the Weizmann
Institute came up with a new algorithm
to do image subtraction so when we think
of a subtraction is very easy you just
take a and do a minus B and an out pops
your subtraction image and and you see
what changed if you when you subtract
the two images it's complicated by the
fact that that astronomers have to
wrangle
atmosphere and the changing conditions
due to the meter per to the wind is
blowing and changes to the point spread
function
so you're basically convolving your PSF
to match the PSF in your reference image
before you do the subtraction so most of
the image subtraction algorithms out
there right now have developed from a
Lardon Lupton i think two decades ago
now but this these algorithms have a
large large number of false positives
and that's what motivated the machine
learning exercise earlier this new
algorithm which is mathematically more
optimal that iran and his graduate
student Barak Saki came up with you can
see that does if you just look at the
difference image this is now a new image
subtract the reference image here's a
difference image if you compare these
two differents images you don't have
much to choose from they look about as
junky and you can see that there are
lots of positive negative Yanks in both
of them
they're not very impressive what is
impressive about this algorithm is that
it deals with the statistical noise
properties of the image much better and
in addition to a difference image it
gives you something called a score image
which tells you the significance of a
source so you can see a very faint trail
here of sources that were injected and
those are the only sources that are
flagged as astrophysically real in this
score image above a threshold of 5 and
you can see that's very very hard you
can maybe if you have very good eyes
make out those images in the salade
induction procedure but they're very
very hard to identify I can give you
another example where your PSFS are
horizontal sorry vertical and the new
imagine horizontal and the reference
image and here I mean something like
this with a symmetric PSFS actually very
clearly subtracts out in the difference
image here but a lot inductance
struggles with this sort of PSF rotation
behavior and again the injected services
are nicely recovered through this
technique so this is something that
the ztf is already adopted in its emit
subtraction algorithms and I believe in
less LSST is also seriously considering
whether to adopt this into their
pipelines the pipeline and itself is
mean has a more complicated flowchart at
each of these boxes come out in two more
boxes I'm showing an oversimplified
version here and it's been written by by
staff scientists at the infrared
processing and analysis Center at
Caltech it's a little bit more serious
in the sense that there's a lot of
documentation deliverables you can't
just go and edit a line in the code
which was something that actually I
loved about the PDF and I PT of
pipelines because you could wake up with
a new idea and by the afternoon
implemented and the code and see the
results that night that's no longer
possible with the CTF pipeline but it is
it is much more robust and reliable and
and very well documented and and and
yeah written by serious computer
scientists no students and postdocs I
would say some but not not exclusively
for example we use things like scamp and
swap which are open source oh geez I
mean I think algorithms open source but
the implementation is is not the entire
code is not open source version changes
right so this is something that I mean
each of the each of the candidates comes
with a version of the both the pipeline
as well as a machine learning algorithm
that's used so you could go back and
keep track of that so everything I mean
everything is version controlled and and
tagged but things won't get V process if
you went and found the line in the code
that you absolutely wanted to change
it's very hard to imagine that there'll
be back pre-processing just because data
volume is very much at least not
immediately okay so after after the
software pipeline that that takes the
image from tonight subtracts from a
reference the previous night
and since here is a list of Canada
transients here's the alert stream and
Eric bumps parlance from the morning
what happens next
and for that you know for the past
decade
we've been developing a piece of code
for astronomers to to be able to
understand and get to the science of
what we want to do this is something
that we call the follow-up Marshall this
is simply you know the destroy Demers
Facebook page so to speak see if you can
log in here and you can see things
specific to your program you can see
what's happened last night what the most
viewed candidates are the things with
the biggest thumbs ups likes on Facebook
but more seriously this is a this is a
way for us to coordinate the follow-up
observations of this large stream of
candidates and here in a very big size I
wanted to highlight an undergraduate
student Chris Cannella who's taken to
school that's evolved over the past
decade for the Palomar transient factory
in them for them to mention farmers
transient factory as we think of new
ways to to adapt the school new ways to
filter the data
new ways to do followup with the data
he's taking the school that sort of been
worked on by many many grad students and
postdocs over the years to sort of clean
it up for used by the by this Vicki
Johnson facility collaboration here and
he's applying for grad school by the way
so in computer science literally five
doors down for me in computer science
okay so let's let's dissect some of
these pages and and their utility here
so step one is filtering right so some
of you will be familiar with the Large
Hadron Collider which has something
called in-situ beamline triggers right
what subset of the data are you
interested in so we have the equivalent
of the beamline triggers which is what
we call filtering the candidates stream
based on a set specific science program
so each science program is actually a
different filter on what this data
stream that's coming through is and each
of them defines this filter and then
presents a list of candidate transients
and then members of that science program
say okay this is garbage this is real
they save these candidates from say the
CTF data stream or any other data stream
actually into the database into the fall
of Marshall database now once you've
saved to Canada to the database you
could get very excited about events and
and get ik extra spectroscopic data or
UV x-ray follow-up with Swift etc so
here's a recent candidate and this
beautiful galaxy here which turned out
to be a stripped and will of supernova
that we got very young and this here is
a like curve the spectrum all kinds of
jabbering of the science team about the
target all kinds of cross matching to
various catalogs here all kinds of
follow-up assignments to this network of
follow-up telescopes that that that you
saw earlier things that you can use to
wake people up they call their cell
phones by by sending them a text message
in the middle of the night or just
sending emails you can subscribe to the
feeds added to your favorites table
whatever you want to do right and it's
actually a lot more stuff that cuts off
the bottom of this slide here so this is
event specific detail about any event in
the database of course when you're
actually writing the papers you want to
know not just something about one event
but all the details of that particular
science program so you want to know end
to end that ok ztf sent a hundred
thousand alerts of that you picked a
hundred because of the filters that you
defined of the 100 you got spectra of 95
I hope it's it's it's at least that good
and and you got that follow up by
telescope a telescope be telescope see
this is what the light curves look like
this is what the distribution and red
shows looks like this for the
distribution and in properties
classification sub-classification looks
like so there's this report page that's
again just dynamically generated based
on the data and the fault of Marshall
again specific to any particular sign
program there's also this Auto
annotations which which is where you
could take your lists of targets and
cross-match to your favorite catalogue
in a different wavelength or in a
different database and again just try to
maximize the science that you that
you're doing with that selected data set
so at this point what I'd like to do is
give you specific examples of why I've
been saying the word speed speed speed
multiple times and speed being essential
to science so I'm going to give you
three examples the first example that
I'm going to save my favorite which is
the gravitational wave event last
because once I start talking about it it
might be hard to stop its way to weight
your fun so I'll save that for the last
but only three examples of where speed
and real time pipelines and and working
closely with computer scientists can
make a huge difference to the science
that a time domain astronomy survey
delivers so the first one is young
supernova so catching a supernova in its
infancy and by which I mean less than 24
hours from the explosion of the star
itself so example number one is see you
have the core collapse of a massive star
see you have a 10 or 15 solar mass star
that undergoes core collapse and
explodes now what you see in look in
this situation for maybe not all but at
least some core collapse events is that
there's a flash in the pan effect so
very early in the first few hours after
explosion you see these extremely high
ionization lines like the helium 140 686
line the nitrogen 4 line the carbon 4
line
I think in this plot there is a oxygen 6
line so very very high ionization states
very very briefly just as a flash in the
pan before the supernova explosion it's
at the blast wave just sweeps it all up
so in a few hours these lines disappear
but these lines are extremely critical
to tell you what sort of progenitor wind
chemistry there is
to diagnose and in some cases you could
look really early and there is nothing
and that also tells us something about
the properties of the start that
actually exploded as a core collapse so
this is one of the motivations to catch
supernovae very very young and then
immediately trigger within a few hours
spectroscopic follow-up but multiple
telescopes around the world to
understand how the the properties of the
star that actually exploded another
example this is a first stripped button
the the type 1 C this is basically a
massive star again which has shipped its
envelope so it stripped not only its
hydrogen envelope but also its helium
envelope this is the only example
actually that we have of a type 1 C
supernova that we caught so early that
we actually see two peaks and the light
curves we see this initial really bright
peak and then the slower peak and then
now you see I'm labeling my spectra and
our words so 14 hours later you see this
helium 240 686 line you see it get
weaker and then you see just disappear
at 33 hours it's gone so in hours after
explosion there's this high ionization
line the helium 240 686 line in
particular which disappears on you and
and after some much analysis if you try
to interpret both the LA the light curve
in the spectra that you see in this
particular case one idea that we've come
up with is that this is an ultra
stripped supernova that is just forming
a compact neutron star binary so this is
sort of the penultimate step to form a
neutron star binary that's compact
enough to merge within within the hubble
time so that's the paper by a graduate
student that's under review right now a
third example for supernova and catching
them really young is exploding white
dwarfs so these are the the types of
supernovae closest to Peter's heart here
and Josh already showed you this in the
morning this is the famous PTF 11 and it
clear why or supernovae 2011
see that has found just 11 hours in
after explosion and I think on last
countable or more than 122 papers
written about this one supernova zone
it's absolutely amazing a discovery and
in this case the type 1a supernova as
Josh mentioned was this was the most
direct proof that this is actually an
exploding white dwarf and the open
question was it seemed like is the
there's something that's causing the
white dwarf to explode but the nature of
the companion is unknown and at least
for this supernova if you read all of
these papers it seems like the consensus
is that the companion to the white dwarf
was another possibly a white dwarf it
wasn't a single degenerate main sequence
or a red giant star that it was that was
its companion on the other hand graduate
student each hour for his thesis the
reason he was working so hard to improve
the pipeline speed was to try to catch
type 1a supernovae early and in her
sample he found the type 1a supernovae
that had this bright UV bump at early
time which was very different from
supernovae 2011 fe and he attributes
this really bright early UV emission to
interaction of the of the supernova with
its companion star so it might be the
type 1a supernovae have different types
of companion stars and the nature of the
companion is something again that very
early data or very rapid response
follow-up in this case by by a satellite
on space the Swift satellite sorry I
that the correct name for that now a
mean-girl swift observatory was able to
do and and this this is again a very
fundamental open science question on the
nature of type 1a supernovae that were
speed matters
okay I'm going to change gears again to
a completely different science case this
is another place where speed matters and
that's relativistic explosions so so of
course relativistic explosions are
gamma-ray bursts
where you have a jet which is Lorentz
factor 400 and that is something that we
have known about and studied for decades
what's new in understanding gamma-ray
bursts is that people are finding
gamma-ray bursts without the gamma rays
so without the assistance of gamma rays
these ground-based optical surveys are
able to discover a phenomena as rare as
gr B's just from the ground so if you
have a wide field camera that's able to
image the sky fast enough and over a
wide enough swath of sky you can find
gamma-ray bursts without the assistance
of gamma rays altogether and in some
cases it's just a question of who saw it
first
so we saw the case of IPT f-14 by B
where we see the optical afterglow of
the gamma-ray burst we discovered it we
announced it and then the gamma-ray
satellites will go back digging in the
data and they find the parents the
gamma-ray parents of this optical
afterglow in some other cases the
gamma-ray parents are not located or not
yet found for example in this case of
PTF 11 AGG we saw an optical afterglow
which looked very much like a gamma-ray
burst but at least so far that the
gamma-ray parents have not been found so
the question is are these often after
blows is there something is there a
mechanism like baryon loading that could
turn off that really high-power jet but
still give you after blow emission in
the optical and and radio wave fans
there's also the amusing case of of
Atlas 1780 hue which was actually
discovered while following up a
gravitational wave trigger again
completely I think independent and
unrelated to the gravitational beatrix
another happy story like Peters of what
follow-up of gravitational waves can do
for you and this Atlas 17 EU had both an
optical and an x-ray afterglow very
similar to normal gamma-ray bursts but
again discovered by the Atlas Survey and
in this case at least we suspect we
might know what the parents GRB is but
the localization of course so somewhat
of a statistical claim then but
something like ztf we expect to find you
know one young supernova of the category
one every night and we expect to find
something like one often afterglow
candidate every month so both of these
science cases are going to speed up in
terms of our understanding of them from
a handful of examples to sample
populations I hope in the very near
future any questions so far
it's the most distinctive very early
feature of certain supernovas very high
ionization states can you imagine any
wild white field spectrograph that would
detect them and could be used to trigger
other observations that's a great
question I mean the most amazing byte
field spectra that's coming online is
the deci servi the prompt and I think
there are plans to look for supernova
even with the Dead Sea survey but it's
more challenging right because you need
on unit spectrum that one thing in the
field which has the Heian ization lines
and usually if you're taking spectra you
need to integrate for a longer over that
that that large field so to get lucky
enough to both find a supernova and for
it to be young enough is it's just the
odds are I think harder but I'll have to
work out the numbers then having about
field optical imaging surveillance is
triggering catching it in time to
trigger a bigger telescope to get that
are sensitive enough to detect these
ionization lines the imaging you have to
have two images with some interval
between them 30 minutes is sort of a
sweet spot to reject the biggest
contaminant which is asteroids so we
need to make sure that that that object
that we think is a supernova did not
move in in 30 minutes and and and
basically we've we've done now for this
ipt of sample response within an hour or
two for about a dozen events
and when CTF I mean the the rate should
be such that as the one every night but
we might only be limited by how much we
can get spectra off because the spectra
need to be done with larger telescopes
like echo Jeremy night
those that aspirate contamination is on
map to asteroids yes yes unknown
asteroids actually it's the Minor Planet
checkers depressingly incomplete when we
go pushed on to 1920-21 magnitude at
17th magnitude I think it's still
respectable and we know about asteroids
and their orbits but add the depths that
we look at the sensitivity that we look
at it's grossly incomplete at it I
wouldn't believe our point at a point a
telescope - anything with a single
detection because chances are it's an
asteroid and to give you an idea of how
bad it is the people who study asteroids
for living when they go to the telescope
to take additional observations they
themselves will take two images to
confirm that the object is moving so
they know where to point the telescope I
think again they people so there's a
whole solar system science working group
as well that uses those those two images
to start to narrow down the uncertainty
in the orbit but they'll get additional
follow-up and I think maybe I mean you
might know these numbers better but I
think you should be three or three or
three images or four images a night out
at a sweet spot for nicely constraining
the orbit so that you can recover it
without like sweet it's still very very
fishy you know so everybody is trying at
least four images in the given night so
that you don't lose
okay so now I'm going to talk about
neutron star mergers and I'm super
excited about this so pardon the extra
excitement but let's let's let's talk
about this so the big deal or I mean the
reason why you know living through an
event like GW 1708 17 was like living
through a legend is that it answers some
very fundamental questions and the first
question that that this neutron star
merger that Alessandro very nicely
described is is where are the heavy
elements in the periodic table
synthesized so as of August 16th 2017
all we knew what were the elements
marked in blue and that the fact that
they were made in super novae half the
elements in the periodic table heavier
than iron so all the yellow marked
elements it was only a matter of
speculation or a theory that these
should be synthesized in merging neutron
stars
we hadn't seen merging neutron stars so
it's hard to believe that that was true
it was a very good educated guess by
Latimer and SRAM in 1974 but there was
no data to back that up and for me that
one of the most spectacular images that
were taken after this event was
localized by the first announcement was
by the Carnegie team using the swoop 40
inch telescope ten hours after the event
but once it was localized you know
several people took several spectrum of
these events and one of the things that
stood out to me the most was that the
infrared spectrum showed these two giant
bumps that no supernova and any library
of supernovae had ever shown before
these bumps were so wide because there
was a large amount of material that was
moving at very high velocities so the
lines were all getting blended amongst
each other but what was remarkable was
that Dan casein right here Berkeley four
years actually now five years ago if you
just take his model predictions of what
sort of spectra do you expect from heavy
elements at a radioactive leader King
that's this red line this is just over
plotting a prediction I'm not
to fit the data at all I'm just over
plotting dance prediction from from five
years ago and it's pretty close he can
even reproduce that the the two bumps of
course I mean this is just one example
of a spectrum there's many many spectra
taken by many many groups all showing
hard evidence that there's absolutely no
question that the infrared emission that
was seen from this neutron star neutron
star merger of August 17th synthesized
at least point zero for solar masses of
heavy elements so this is more than
10,000 orth masses of heavy elements
it's a really large quantity of heavy
elements as elements marked in yellow
that was synthesized what you see in
this movie is a sequence of spectra
taken by the years taken with VLT egg
shooter by my collaborator the Nepean
and you can see that the bumps and
Wiggles in the spectra and how they
evolve as a function of time this is
where all the nuclear physics lies and
and I believe you know this is one of
several data sets that that theorists
will model for for many years to come to
try and figure out which elements in
particular of these elements with atomic
mass numbers between 70 and 200 which is
something like 130 elements which
elements are actually contributing to
the to these lines and invert relative
proportion so there's a whole suite of
nuclear physics that can be done thanks
to these beautiful spectrum that were
collected on almost a nightly basis by
many many different groups all coming to
the same conclusion that that no matter
how you look at the data no matter what
analysis you do there's no question that
neutrons are mergers are a prolific site
of our process nuclear synthesis the the
process by which you synthesize heavy
elements in the periodic table so it was
the first science question that that the
rapid follow-up campaign that involved
70 observatories around the world and as
Josh pointed out 3,600 something I think
basically all those draw all the time to
mean astronomers in the world
in did for you the second question that
I'd like to point out here is the jet
physics so Alessandra mentioned to you
that there was a burst of gamma rays
that were seen two seconds after the
event and this event thought you saw
emission from across the entire
electromagnetic spectrum so you saw the
two neutron stars merge and then two
seconds later you saw a burst of gamma
rays and then about ten and a half hours
later the optical emission was seen and
the infrared emission and then fourteen
hours was a UV emission and then nine
days later you saw x-ray photons and
then 16 days later you so read your
photons so every single band in the
electromagnetic spectrum we lit up for
this particular event such that you
could get to the heart of the jet
physics that's actually driving the
emission in this particular case now one
would naively at first blush think that
okay we saw a burst of gamma rays the
burst was pretty short it was two
seconds so what we saw in this case was
a shorter gamma-ray burst coming from
neutron star neutron star mergers
unfortunately that that picture is not
right this can either be so this relates
the first two surprises in the emission
so the infrared I mean I said as I said
the theories got an A+ grade that they
were very spot on but at all the other
wavelengths they were struggling a bit
more so Alice and writing briefly
mentioned that the gamma-ray emission
was actually ten thousand times weaker
intrinsically less luminous wimpier than
the gamma emission scene and
cosmological shorter gamma-ray bursts
and the second surprise was that the
x-ray and radio emission came after a
long wait it was actually delayed by by
many days 90s for the x-ray and sixteen
days for the radio and it's continuing
to rise even now right I mean all the
way up more than hundred days after the
demerger it's continuing to rise so what
this means is that the canonical jet
model that's invoked for gamma-ray
bursts is not true
the the gamma-ray burst is so weak that
there's no way you could have an
intrinsically such a weak gamma-ray
burst break out of the material so you
cannot be seen an on axis gamma-ray
burst
you could also not be seeing an off-axis
gamma-ray burst because these two Clues
give you two different viewing angles so
see you had a jet in this direction and
you were looking at the jet of axis so
just a few degrees of axis then the fact
that the gamma rays were ten thousand
times weaker means that you were point
one Radian not five or six degrees of
axis to see that to explain that observe
gamma-ray emission but the radio and
x-ray the fact that the onset was so
delayed and the shape was was so slowly
rising for such a long time means that
you can't be just five or six degrees
off-axis you need to be something like
20 30 maybe 40 degrees of axis so given
that we only live on one planet Earth
which is where all of our telescopes are
or on or around you can't have two lines
of sight to the same event so you cannot
simultaneously explain this with an
off-axis gamma-ray burst model the third
surprise was that thanks to these 70
telescopes around the world collecting
data in many different UV optical
infrared bands the UV data's from again
from the Swift observatory the emission
in the in the UV optical bands was
extremely bright and extremely blue for
a very long time so the infrared
emission is easy to explain as heavy
element radioactive decay but the
optical emission which lasts for so long
is much harder to explain in this
context and this it doesn't matter you
know which data set or which subset of
which data set you look at the
conclusion is still the same is that is
that it's very bright and blue at early
times so in order to explain these three
surprises we proposed a model called the
cocoon breakout model so what we see
here is that you have these two neutron
star mergers and as they come closer and
closer together there's it
out of tidal fields and not a material
that's been thrown out in the
surrounding medium so the so when the
jet is actually it's when the two
neutron stars merge and a jet is
launched the jet is not launched into a
clean environment the jet is launched
into Amity into a lot of material such
that the jet actually gets stuck and
this jet transfers its some of its
energy some or all of its energy into
the surrounding medium given that the
jet has so much energy it's a it's a
it's a Lawrence factor of hundred jet
right moving at which is at 0.99 nine
times the speed of light once the
transfers all this energy into the
surrounding medium what it can do is
that the surrounding medium itself can
form what we call a cocoon which is
wide-angle mildly relativistic so when I
say my leader the to the stick I mean
Lorentz factor of two to three which is
still pretty fast it's in about 0.9
times the speed of light so the word
mild is only relative to something
that's a Lorentz factor of 100 and much
much faster but if so much material say
0.05 solar masses of material gets
accelerated to such a high speed then
this this wide-angle mildly relativistic
cocoon it could break out and give you
an independent source of gamma rays so
when so this can explain the things that
we see which is that as Alessandra told
you after the neutron star merger and
the gravitational waves that came from
it there was a two-second actually 1.7
seconds to be precise time lag before
the bursts of gamma rays were seen so
the time lag is because of the time it
takes for this cocoon to break out the
fact that it is intrinsically less
luminous is directly related to again
this wide angle and the slow slow speed
of the material so the low luminosity
gamma rays are easy to explain again
because it's slower it's nicely explains
the delay in the onset of the radio and
x-ray emission and then this continued
rise over a hundred days and then the
fact that all this material is now
accelerated to 0.9 times the speed of
light means just by Doppler boosting you
can explain the early blue
mission that was bright for so long so
very nicely this model can can address
the puzzle seen in the electromagnetic
spectrum
so looking down the road a little bit
you could certainly imagine different
mass neutron stars merging that could
have dirtier environments or
environments so one could really expect
that this picture could change radically
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely
in fact so let's go to the extreme value
for my neutrons a black hole module
where the mass ratios is very high in
that case all the dynamic of the breeze
and in the in the equatorial plane so
you don't have any stuff to form your
cocoon the cocoon does require material
to be spread all around and that would
not happen if the mass ratio between the
neutron Sun black hole is very large so
that's why for neutron star black hole
mergers the most models predict that
there be no UV optical emission the
emission will be exclusively in the
infrared wave bands and be pretty hard
to find unless you build the wide-field
infrared camera to do that the other big
question is what is the fate of the jet
that form the cocoon did the cocoon
broke out that's what we see right now
but did the jet also escape such that
say your friends are on alien
civilization someone somewhere in the
universe still saw a short hot gamma ray
burst and I think that's very much an
open question because a we don't have
friends on that alien civilization and
the perfect position just yet and B we
have not they're not seeing any evidence
of that jet just yet but we're
continuing to collect data continuing to
hoping towards to see some evidence for
the jet because absence of evidence is
not evidence of absence so I think
that's very much an open question as to
what happened to that jet that gave rise
to the cocoon one more thing that I'd
like to mention on the topic of GW 1708
17 is race and this is again where you
know the power of two graduate students
working with Peter and what computer
science can do for you so the entire
life of a go collaboration came up with
the rate on the neutrons are neutron
mergers of 322 4740 buggy capacity
appear what I want you to take away from
that rate is that it's uncertain by more
than an order of magnitude that's the
main thing I wanted to take away from
the first line what Peter figured out
was that this particular event the
counterpart was so bright that it would
have been so easy to find in the pj of
data that we have for the past decade so
with two of two graduate students he he
figured out a way to go through the
entire database at lightning speed and
see if there was an event like GW 1708
17 hiding in our database that we
somehow missed and it doesn't seem like
we missed anything and so he can place a
pretty firm limit on then based on the
non detection of less than 800 perdida
parts a cube per year so this reduces
the uncertainty from an order of
magnitude to only a factor of I guess
two less than three factor of three in
the rate that is really cool because the
reason the rate is important is that now
everybody's convinced that neutrons are
mergers is where all these heavy
elements are synthesized so the question
is are these the only places are they
not only a site of our process nuclear
synthesis but the site of heavy element
reduction and if you if you take point
zero five so the masses of ejecta that's
contributing to the heavy elements that
that we see based on the infrared data
and you multiply by a number that's in
between the 300 from LIGO and the 800
from Peter then this you can say you
take 500 per gigawatt a cube per year
the product of this actually equals the
observed solar abundance so so it may be
depending on innovated stance is closer
to 300 or 800 but those really high
numbers are very problematic from LIGO
because they over produce the observed
solar abundances of course there's a
third parameter Y on how well the
material that's produced is mixed in and
whether it's more uniformly distributed
how does a sun-like system differ from
other environments so on and so forth so
samples will even answer this well but
this is just to illustrate again that
Peters lightning fast
query of this data base to pull out GW
1708 17 leg events after we saw it was
able to reduce the uncertainty in rates
from more than an order of magnitude to
less than a factor of three okay so in
summary as was pointed out by Eric and
then Josh and then Alessandra this is a
fun time and time domain astronomy
the past was turned to the four vents
per night the present has begun with
this Vicki transient facility and ten to
the five events per night and LSSC would
be 10 to the 6 events per night so
things are changing by an order of
magnitude as we as we see in the course
of just few years and to really get to
the heart of some of the the key science
that time domain astronomers want to
answer I think a partnership between
astronomers and computer scientists is
essential it's there's no no question at
least in my mind about that and with
that I'd like to thank you very much for
your time and attention and take any
questions we have we have one question
here the black hole black hole and this
actually us to alessandra to wanted to
know what do you think are the prospects
of it seeing anything in the optical or
IR from the black hole black hole
mergers okay as I can double my views my
honest opinion is that black holes are
very black so but there is I mean the
most compelling model I would say there
are a bazillion models out there on
black wedlocke Rogers and possible
scenarios for actual magnetic radiation
but the most compelling model is that if
in addition to two black holes you had a
companion a third thing in the system
and that was some are lighting up the
material but to get all the details
right that might only happen in 1% or
less of the systems but that at least to
me is the picture is most compelling but
overall you know black holes are pretty
black
but Alessandra may have a different view
so is it worthwhile to follow them up
that's that's the question so I think I
mean and after how many non detections
would you say okay you know I'll do it
if I've got the time but otherwise I'm
not going to bother me so so far but but
PTF and I have it sorted with the PDF
and IPTV followed up every single
trigger that LIGO centers that we could
access we have made no discrimination
based on either significance mean we
followed up complete things that were
complete garbage later black holes like
hold events neutral I mean anything that
we could follow up before the table but
moving forward I would say I mean but
this Vicki transit facility there might
be time restrictions that I imposed on
us and we will we don't plan to follow a
black code black code modules but I know
there are the survey's out there that
are even more committed to gravitational
we follow up of everything and meet they
might follow Blackwood back and watch us
as well Armand she said the combo part
will be very faint
it's a previous purchase research other
areas for like hundreds or even
thousands more square it means it's next
for speed when we expect you know a
better on the order of like 100 or 200
of them will have very good local
disease more like what 30 or 60 square
degrees these errors you can then go and
wheelie
- twenty-three or twenty-four
twenty-fifths maybe to vdd I think this
will be the first meaningful constraints
on that I mean right now that was the
area was just too big to get anything to
shallow I think did you find something
atheism I expect you know and so and
then you have the thousands of enemies
for five minutes really Greece was like
200 words Superbowl wait happening
that's just no chance that you can find
something like that do you believe
there's Astrophysical picture that is
sufficiently compelling for if I would
have bet my house I would say no we can
look for two years and spend a small
elephant is more telescope time to grow
and we look to twenty fourth magnitude
I think that's F near parents page you
would like to go
how'd the Dumber they come to par
healthy right the Northwest Indians is
the fair mean transient that was fine
typical or not because then if you have
some memory under par you would
inference you know make some
extrapolations of what's the enemy
in massive galaxies some homes it's more
is a relatively small trance but yeah I
mean successfully please leave sixty
square degrees you can really come up be
easy no but they can you know you go to
the course maybe two really easily and
ten pointings and you have at least
twenty given 60 so this is as allison is
pointing out the gamma rays come for
free right because for me is looking at
big chunks of the sky all the time
anyway so by the way something that
neither of you pointed out that i think
is the most incredible thing about the
GRB observation two seconds afterwards
is it destroyed many alternative
theories to general relativity with
justification so that is one of the
coolest thing because i hate i don't
heat theorists but I hate theorists who
come up with theories that can't be
tested and a lot of these theories fall
into that they did make one prediction
which is that the gravitational waves
should be much slower and they weren't
and so this is a that was a great great
observation the testability observations
of these high-energy events
fired following a large box appears have
any bearing on dark matter indications
oh so this is actually I mean even with
money burned people are ready to do
cosmology so so basically this is what
they call it sort of like the standard
candle approach that people use with
type 1a supernovae as collaborators this
is not the standard siren approach so
LIGO in addition to telling you that if
it was localized within 30 square
degrees also told us that it was
localized speed 40 plus or minus 8 mega
parsec so it also gives you a distance
constraint in addition to the area
constraint and you know the right answer
by looking at the distance from
electromagnetic observations that it was
exactly 40 plus minus 1 mega parsec and
by combining these two independent sets
of information you could once again
derive the value of H naught and
cosmology and the rate of rate at which
the universe is expanding and
implications in dark matter dark energy
although I mean all the things that you
can do with cosmology but of course one
event is is very hard I mean the it's
consistent with everything right now but
but with samples of events the certainly
a group of aficionados want to very
seriously use them for cosmology
applications whether it'll be more
precise and more constraining than type
1a supernovae and plank constraints and
H naught is is debatable but it's an
independent robe which is school
if I understand correctly the brightness
and blueness of the radiation from the
cocoon is a blue shifting a Doppler
glue-sniffing wouldn't it be a great
confirmation of that hypothesis if you
could detect the corresponding red
shifted emission from the other side of
the cocoon well you're seeing the blue
shifted part is what's coming towards us
at 0.9 C unfortunately it gets blocked
by the blue shifting part so you can't
see through it it's optically you're
totally okay yeah it's totally fake yes
your friend with that makes make some
friends with the aliens right we
couldn't get all different lines of
sides right and telescopes as good as us
it or better that but yeah that would be
a very good that sort of me a valid
think that should happen is that it's
not just one direction of the cocoon is
there definitely things happening in
backside but there are other ideas to
explain the early permission one is the
stopler boosting by the cocoon and other
ideas that you're just lowering the
opacity because of a disc wind that need
but neutrinos that are just a radiating
and they're just lowering the opacity in
the in the polar regions and I would say
you know the biggest missing clue
the biggest frustration and the data
said that I have a GW 1708 17 is that
there's no data between two seconds
later when we saw the gamma rays and
then ten and a half hours later when
Arman and his team found the optical
counterpart so there's a big hole there
and and that can tell you I mean and
whether you see the UV emission rise or
dude make about ride rise and decline in
that first few hours could distinguish
between these four different models to
try and explain the early blue emission
so UV satellite that can be their spa
hour the missing hours
because people didn't have the right I
mean I'm very much of an outsider see
the Atlantic Ocean yeah it was most
mostly they're boring which is that the
rotation of the earth came into the
picture so this particular area was very
close to the Sun and at the time that
the trigger key it was a bump Western
Australia it could be accessed from this
in Australia but as Alessandro showed in
her timeline it took five hours before
they were able to send out the map so by
that time the it shifted over South
Africa but it was actually already past
South Africa was already in the Atlantic
Ocean by the time the tighter map came
so you just had to keep waiting for
another five and a half hours to cross
the Atlantic and for the Sun to set in
Chile and when the Sun set and Chile
they were each telescopes that were all
observing and looking for the
counterfeit right so Armand's team at
Swope was the first to announce but
there were seven other teams that it was
so bright that also saw that the
counterpart within minutes of each other
it's only for the first event for future
events it's actually a function of what
the eye goes quadrupole antennae
sensitivity patterns
so both Hanford and Louisiana are
aligned so all the northern events
should be directly above North America
which thankfully has lots of telescopes
the southern events will be over Western
Australia and have this systematic
rotation problem to Chile or to Russia
but once more go Rams up in sensitivity
any of three interferometers then there
should be more of an isotropic it's only
a nighttime daytime question but if you
go into space right even in this
particular case if it there was a UV
satellite like the satellite that was
marching down a galaxy list they just
marched on at galaxy less in a slightly
different order they flew to the
position within five minutes of getting
the trigger so they could have gotten UV
data had they chosen the order on which
they marched on the galaxy lister
friendly so it was not impossible to get
on target sigma so that's my biggest
regret with this is that we could have
been the even faster
we actually could speak talk as equals
like one hour after the first image was
feeding and so that was because it's my
team it's am only member of the team and
but they were so fast that within an
hour they had some German school point
that stores and go to the spectrum it's
an inspector that you have from this
first night following up full of
spectrography the next day
there's also me the importance you get
respect or trust to verify it's not just
like a normal super movie I mean that's
big that's a very long and it would be
something else it was definitely this
garden variety type on a Titan people
like you know any it could not be 90
percent of the super Nuria Peter lost a
bet and so the next night that was much
higher emergency I would say then if it
would have been not business expect hey
this is an unusual transient give me the
temptation of a yeah I would say I
didn't believe it when I saw that
infrared spectrum right I mean this
thing became I mean the optical just
dropped like a rock and then shred just
roses and then you could see these giant
bumps and the infrared which is just
like nothing we had ever seen before
I mean that was just completely amazing
I mean there's no question I think
there's no paper is written that this
particular counterpart is not related to
the gravitational wave event I mean
there were I think 120 Papers written on
this object by competing groups with
competing ideas on interpretation and
different data sets but not a single
group who says that that's all
associated because Association the data
is irrefutable
but because of this first day they've up
that was already immediately chance this
is a queue no not for sure 20 any a
transient to let spectra it's not a
normal type where types Super Bowl and
that nobody can really literally tweak
up everything which has been done all
wait you are in every single trigger and
that probably would have a little bit
more hesitant people be more hesitant to
trigger something without the speed
again is very important in this game
system being taken why don't we think
Mon see again and then let's set out to
the reception
[Applause]